hi hello everyone and welcome
to my presentation on point of care
testing integrated into clinical care
improving cardiac outcomes in rural
areas i'd like to thank the organizers
for this opportunity to talk about um a
piece of work that has been um
the bulk of my professional life for the
last 13 years
considerable body of work has been done
um around the inequity of cardiac
outcomes in rural remote areas and a
paper by sexton sexton in 2000 actually
reported that more deaths and expected
occur from acute myocardial infarction
in ruin remote areas
which resulted in a higher mortality
rates from currently heart disease
approximately half 30 percent higher in
men and 21 higher in women
living outside of capital cities
if you think about the um the factors
that contribute to the geographical
variations in coronary heart disease
outcomes they include your demographics
age sex
ethnic background of your population
socioeconomic factors
risk factor prevalence
you know smoking lipids hypertension
diabetes obesity sedentary lifestyle and
of course you've got um
treatment factors in involved in
individual cases
if you look at south australia where i
come from
you can see we have a vast geographical
area
our area although larger than a lot of
european countries has only a fraction
of the
population that perhaps a 30th in some
instances or 40th of the population so
that brings about huge challenges when
delivering health services
if you look at the yellow stars on the
map that's where the pathology
laboratories are located so you can see
there's last areas where there are no
pathology laboratories
for uh hospitals or the patients in
these areas
so our rural health service has a
population of around 420 000 people
40 of these people are greater than 65
years of age
we have 66 country hospitals providing
24 7.
a couple of smaller sites now no longer
provide 24 7 cover but there is a close
regional hospital that takes care of
that catchment populations are anything
from fifteen hundred to thirty thousand
per hospital
as i mentioned there's only about ten
on-site laboratories in the rural areas
we have a significant shortage of
doctors and nurses in primary care and
hospitals and have a high proportion of
overseas trained doctors working in
south australia
um there's a significant shortage of
medical specialists and only there's
only three adult consultant physicians
operating in rural areas
and teaching and tertiary hospitals are
highly centralized
in terms of the bad
in our australian healthcare we're
highly urbanized which the map showed
certainly for south australia with
extremely low population density outside
of the major earth urban centers
our health center is very fragmented
there's barriers between the
commonwealth and state state to state
barriers and of course you have your
metropolitan regional remote
barriers and differences
and we have a real lack of health
information systems across australia
so we lack
have a lack of systems for safety
quality um and cost-effectiveness and
really our systems are unsustainable in
terms of inequity of outcomes
inefficiencies there's over dependence
on acute hospital care
and the workforce capacity
along with the bad we actually have a
changing practice environment with
increasing numbers of the elderly much
more chronic disease that we have to
deal with
um there's workforce shortages i've
mentioned already medical cost pressures
income increased demand for patient
safety increased demand for optimal and
equitable outcomes
and really universal application of
medical evidence you know making sure
that we are practicing evidence-based
care
there's rapidly involving therapeutic
possibilities and new technology
some of which are hard to implement in
our rural remote areas
um we have a demand in our um you know
changing practice environment for
increased sufficient efficiency
um increased throughput cost
effectiveness really there's a greater
accountability for processes of care and
outcomes
and you know we're trying to remove the
barriers for and impediments for
evidence-based care
we have to really embrace new ways of
delivering care and and have a more
team-based multi-disciplinary care
clearly we want to paste it patient
centric
model of care there's role redefinition
a one-stop care really clinic home-based
delivery local capacity um and we need
to re-engineer and redesign how we
actually are offering our health
services to be more efficient and of
course we do need the data collection
collection analysis and feedback
increase it increase integrated into the
process of care for continual quality
improvement
so what is our problem well coronary
heart disease incidence morbidity and
mortality rates continue to be higher
across all groups in rural remote areas
compared with the urban areas in
australia
the practice of cardiac care differs
according to the geographic location
specialty of the practicing physician
and teaching status of the hospital
a lot of our or prior to implementing
point of care a lot of our rural health
centers had to wait up to 24 hours for
routine blood tests which were commonly
available in there in areas between one
and two hours so you know from a
perspective of a troponin if you were a
little remote
um hospital that was four or about four
hours away from a laboratory
you may actually have have to wait 24
hours and on the weekend even up to 48
or more hours for a result and clearly
that that test becomes um not part of
the the timely medical services you
actually have to treat your patient
without that test
so our research question when we started
this project was does the limited access
to evidence-based care in middle areas
that this may be explained by the
um
access to care may explain the
differential
in outcomes between coronary heart
disease and urban and rural population
and that was the hypothesis for our
research
so um we started our research and um
and we actually were successful in in
getting a commonwealth grant to look at
this um
and what we did initially is consulted
with the rural clinicians trying to
identify the three areas for improved
patient care what was preventing them
from
practicing evidence-based cardiac care
and the three things that they really um
were quite um
uniform about were
their their need for advice with ecg
interpretation
better access to biochemical markers
within the recommended time frame and
access to advice from a consultant
cardiologist
so we set about trying to come up with a
solution to these issues
and icarnet which is now known as icc
net country health south australia was
established in 2001. it was established
to support rural gps in the delivery of
up-to-date evidence-based
management patients presenting with
chest pain or other symptoms suggestive
of acute corneal syndrome in in the
southeast of south australia in the
first instance
it was designed to support gps by
providing a bedside cardiac marker
testing
evidence-based triage and management
guidelines and a 24-hour on-call
cardiologist
we received in 2006 funding of 1.3
million over four years which was
announced by a health minister to
actually extend our research project
which was looking to be um
quite um
well accepted and successful throughout
the country region
so what were the principles and
objectives of our program well they were
to support the primary care doctor in
the diagnosis of acute
management of cardiac conditions
it was to enhance the clinical autonomy
of the primary care doctor and promote
the importance of primary care doctor
patient relationship we didn't want to
come in and take over we really wanted
to just to be their support base and be
there in the background if they required
our assistance
we needed to accommodate different
levels of experience and
different confidence levels
of the doctors dealing with the acute
cardiac
cardiac problems in their hospitals
so
our
way of doing this was to bring together
all the participants in real cardiac
care
and this is included getting hospital
management buy-in
engaging the primary care doctors
and engaging the regional consultant
physicians
the emergency and cardiac nursing staff
the community and regional hospital
services including emergency departments
chronic care units hcus
bringing in point of care pathology
engaging the cardiologists who supported
these hospitals the intensive care
retrieval service ambulances and the
surgeons who had to do the invasive
surgery when required for these patients
so enablers of our clinical networks or
our clinical resources that we used were
integrated evidence-based um
clinical pathways for chest pain and
acute coronary syndromes they were
triage protocols they had diagnostic
stratification protocols and treatment
protocols and these are all enrolled
into one and i'll show you what it kind
of looks like in a minute
um we introduced point of care pathology
in all these hospitals and so for the
first time they could actually get a
troponin result within 15 minutes
and we set up a system so they had
improved accessibility consultant
cardiologists um advice 24 hours a day
seven days a week and we monitor the
response time and
our performance indicator is that we
will respond to these requests within 10
minutes and we we meet that probably
about 85 percent of the time
we had to improve access to
tertiary
cardiac services through service
integration
we came up across an issue where the
thrombolytics for st elevation mi a lot
of our hospitals didn't have it because
it was expensive
they didn't use it they would be
throwing it out because it would expire
so we set up a rotation system with all
our hospitals to ensure that everyone
had the drug and minimum
amount of the drug would be thrown out
um we were always interested in cardiac
rehabilitation because of course once
these people had an event and something
had to be done to educate them on how to
deal with their disease
of course staff training um
and cme was extremely important bringing
people up to up to speed of what the
evidence base was for cardiac care
and without doubt you know it's
extremely important to what we do
so
what was the role of planner care
testing in our initial setup well point
of care was really required to enable
risk stratification of the cardiac
patients
it was it was critical
to developing
evidence-based cardiac care in our rural
areas it was designed and implemented
we designed and implemented a cardiac
network incorporating point of care
run within a quality framework um the
physician acute needs resulted in a an
expanded range of point of care tests
which um we've slowly been introducing
as time goes on
this is the big pathway that sits in in
our
emergency departments and you guys
probably won't be able to see it very
well on your slide but it basically
tells them what to do as the patient
hits the emergency department
what drugs to consider what tests need
to be done you know when the troponins
need to be repeated
when they need to consider transferring
them um to adelaide for invasive testing
and it's really the bible of acute
coronary syndrome in their hospitals
it's endorsed by the cardiology clinical
network
and it's a very popular
pathway in our emergency departments
across our 66 hospitals
so when a ketchup onion differentiates
between unstable angina and non-st
elevation mr that's really the main
purpose of using draponin as a wrist
stratification tool because i had
slightly different treatments for
unstable angina versus and on stemi
it really enables us to have an informed
decision on which patients need to
transfer to tertiary hospital for
invasive cardiac testing
and really prevents the unnecessary
transfer of patients who are low risk
for acute chronic syndrome and can be
managed safely in their local hospital
before we set up these protocols
when we reviewed what patients were
being transferred they were even stable
anginas that could you know quite easily
have been
managed in their in their own town with
less destruction to the family unit
that were being transferred to adelaide
so certainly our systems have improved
we have increased transfers because
that's part of the evidence base you
know that high-risk patients do need to
transfer to adelaide but we've stopped
the transfer of the patients who don't
require it
so we had to implement point of care
really across all our hospitals
we did this with
on-site training
further training is supplied by video
conferencing we're lucky in south
australia that considerable amount of
money has been put into video
conferencing across all the hospitals so
across our health network we can
actually video conference into every
hospital
and provide training and education
that same video conferencing equipment
is used for clinical consults emergency
clinical consults for cardiology and
certainly um
psychiatry in particular which is what's
what initiated the setup of the video
conferencing suites in country so it's a
fantastic resource and it really helps
us
support all our hospitals without having
to travel to them all the time
we also use webinars
for continuing in education employment
care testing both technically and
clinical um
reasons for
all our hospitals have uh documentation
on all of their
point of care methods
they actually have a folder with all
this information um and on our website
and there's online copies of basically
all the information that they require
to run their tests
we have along as well as having the
cardiologist support we have a technical
support hotline as well so there's a
clinical scientist that's on call 24 7.
and um
we're really on call to support
them if
people who may not use the equipment
very often and and need um some
prompting along the way
or if there's a an error and some of the
things we can sort out and sometimes in
a clearly we can't and our way of
troubleshooting is if we can't sort it
out with some basic um getting him to
answer basic questions and check some
basic things we um
then basically have to pull that
instrument and rather than go out there
to have a look at it which is not
well we need lots of stuff to be able to
do that we have
spare instruments in town and we send up
with over overnight to the hospital it
does sometimes mean that these hospitals
may be without the technology for a wee
bit but um
that's probably the best we can do
insights that have a high throughput of
patients we tend to have at least two
machines there to cover um
those instances but we've been pretty
lucky touchwood that most of the
equipment we choose has been extremely
reliable for us
so we have a training program as i said
we have a variety of ways of offering
that training program and we really go
through the performance characteristics
you know how to get a good you know the
patient preparation and sample
collection because of course if you
don't have a good sample you're not
going to get a good result
reagent preparation storage how to
perform the tests the principles and
practice of quality control and external
quality assurance
maintenance and and common
troubleshooting although most people i
have to say that troubleshooting is to
dial the technical support line
um
occupational health and safety issues
compliance with accreditation
recording of results interpretation of
results and really where do they go if
they need help
we have a quality program throughout icc
net it's mandatory for the sites to
participate in both the internal and
external quality programs
when we first started excuse me
um
we were
essentially an external provider or part
of another health network and um we had
to get the
um agreement from management before we
started into the hospital
with with our program
these days as i'll talk a bit about
later we're actually part of country
health so that makes it much easier um
we come up with recommendations on how
point of care should be run through our
country and those rules and regulations
um have to be followed across all our
hospitals and certainly
um
participating in quality control
programs is is high on our list of what
they have to do if they want to continue
doing testing
the site submit the results to the um
icc in the office every month that's
actually changed now because we have
gone electronic and i'll talk a little
bit about that soon
um
with their eqa we send out monthly
reports to the hospitals to let them
know how how they're doing and you know
how their result compares to everybody
else
um in the traditional eqa way
our nurses perform the qc tests um when
we actually distribute all the
consumables from our central office
and before we do that we do run batch
qcs in our office to make sure that the
lot numbers we are sending out um
are appropriate
we do have some challenges across uh you
know 66 hospitals that we run and that's
yeah nursing staff who have um lots of
jobs and certainly as i said a shortage
of them remembering to do the qcnqa
most hospitals understand the need for
of it and it's not they don't want to do
it it's actually just remembering to do
it
um a lot of hospitals rely on one nurse
to perform the qc
and the qa testing we try and discourage
that and have it that when it's due
whoever's on on shift will do it
um
but you know we still haven't converted
all our hospitals i don't think
um clearly sometimes the storage and
reconstitution of the samples is a bit
of an issue
and i'll show you how we sort of rectify
that um
correction action on descriptive results
getting them to actually report them to
us
yeah we have to transport frozen
liquid qc qa samples across you know
vast distances
um and that that is is challenging
particularly in our summer when it's
extremely hot and
um yeah we run the risk of the samples
being um
destroyed before they even get to our
hospitals
um and of course the costs
this graph shows a site where we were
finding that their internal qcs for
troponin were probably um much more
variable than what we had had hoped so
we were concerned that perhaps
um
it was to do with the making up of the
qc so what we started to do was actually
make up the qcs
in our central office and send them the
frozen sample and interestingly enough
you can see that really tightened the
cvs
considerably
so we then had to sort of
do some education on reconstitution and
the importance of making sure the right
volume and the right time and doing the
test in appropriate
time time frame
to get these uh tightened
cvs
so what are the benefits of
point of care within a clinical network
well clearly um you can have
standardized instrumentation and medic
method selection across a network then
that's extremely important to us in
particular for troponin if we had some
sites who did a troponin tea and some
who didn't i that would be um
problematic not their eyes are bad
marker it's just that the the
cardiologist on the phone would have to
remember to ask um which method are you
using and what is your reference
interval this way we have
one test um
and the cardiologists uncle are well
aware of how that test performs the
limitations of that test
and it certainly doesn't cause us any
sort of errors in terms of
result interpretation
being within a clinical network we can
integrate the test into a clinical
pathway as i showed you that big pathway
that we have on our um
emergency department walls we have one
policy that's shared amongst all our
health centres
and the central management of training
support and qc monitoring
we have for our um
66 hospitals in addition to myself we
have three other
medical scientists that support the
point of care networking country
so the important features for a point of
care service which is managed offsite is
really selection of appropriate
equipment because
if you have good equipment and have good
training and education
around
that use of that equipment you don't
have a technical support line that gets
lots of calls
we currently
out of ours would
maybe get one you know a couple of calls
um
a week
we we um tend to get most of our
technical support calls during the day
and it's usually around qc qa or using
our databases so we're quite pleased
that the
level of training we give our sites is
adequate enough because we don't get a
lot of
please help calls
it's important that this that the the
nurses and doctors have really a good
clinical understanding of the results
you know normally um the results are
done in the pathology laboratory and the
lab really acts as a safety net for
those results before they go out to
clinicians with point of care you're
removing that safety net so the doctor
has to um be aware of issues that might
affect that result you know in
particular you know the pre-analytical
issues
you need uh clear concise instructions
for your methods
um electronic capture of qc results
is great
technical support clearly is um
important having good troubleshooting
mechanisms
and i.t without it basically the
challenges are tenfold i'd have to say
so if you look at our network um
implementation timelines the project
commenced in september 2000 that's when
i commenced working on the project we
had our pilot network
in 2001
in 2003 we had the fully regional
network which was completed across the
south east and that was funded by the
commonwealth government
a commitment to go statewide went around
2004 and that's really because all the
hospitals started ringing
learning about the service and ringing
and saying please can we join please
come and join so even though we weren't
really funded to do all of country we
started creeping out into all country um
towns that wanted the service
the statewide network was completed
basically in 2008
in 2010
country health that were had been
funding that network since 2006
decided to incorporate the um the
research network basically into um
into their clinical service so we became
the cardiology department of country
health so i'd have to say this is one of
those
um
you know exciting journeys where your
research actually trains translates into
a clinical service and now um my staff
rather myself and my staff rather than
having to get
budgets and grants every three years we
are all just temporary employees and
sorry permanent employees
of country health uh in south australia
so um our network is really
patient
focused
um evidence-based it's systematic it's
compromisive and population level focus
but yeah the most important thing is
that it is a patient-focused network and
will do everything really in our power
to ensure that the rural patients get
the best cardiology care that they can
if you look at the clinical resources we
use in our hospitals
we um over the last couple of years
having stored a digital ecg management
system which really
gives
you beautiful digital images of ecg's
which can be emailed to the on-call
cardiologist
it means that across country any patient
can review ecg's
um
from any other hospital within country
health and
certainly they can call up previous ecgs
and see if the changes
are new or if they're already there
our paging service just to give you an
indication
it's a 24 7 service the aim is less than
10 minute response time there's a single
statewide telephone number and it has a
built-in redundancy so there's
um
the cardiologist who gets the call has
to actually accept the call if he
doesn't it goes on to the next
cardiologist who's on call we at any one
time have five cardiologists on call and
at the end of the line is it reverts to
the technical support hotline and us
scientists will then um
not respond to the call clearly because
we're not cardiologists but we will find
a cardiologist to take that call as soon
as we can
um these are the instruments that
we have in our network
um
the extended care
point of care that we actually
use
nt pro bmp course for your heart failure
patients d-dimer hemoglobin and white
cell count is increasingly getting
popular
as of
last june
now
all our hospitals can do
basically troponin and their
electrolytes and blood gases so
um country health um put up the capital
to put um
we actually went with the epochs epochs
into our country hospitals so we do have
a few istants out there but um because
of the epoch having room temperature
consumables it's much more suitable for
us in a rural network it's easier to
transport items so
that was a fantastic achievement really
that to know then that a basic
electrolyte and blood gas could be done
in all of our hospitals when previously
if they needed monitoring of the
electrolytes they would have to be
transferred to adelaide to get that done
we
actually uh over the last
probably 18 months have been developing
a point of care pathology database and
the system's really designed to accept
pathology requests record and chart
patient results
generate pathology reports download and
ch chart quality control results
excuse me
order consumables and track usage
um it's with web-based and it's actually
um sits in our demilitarized zone in
health which makes it accessible to our
doctors who are outside of the health
network to retrieve these results
um we are about to actually launch that
our ecg database which sits
on the intranet and can't be viewed
outside of health we're actually
about to get the ecgs also transported
to our point of care database
and so doctors will be able to retrieve
their point of care results and the ecg
results from their surgeries all at home
at night if they're on course so that's
a huge um
achievement for us as well so this is
just a a look at what our pathology
request form looks like
um
a database looks like here we have tabs
for um
the different panels of tests so they're
easier um
to
to view
and that's just an example of a
pathology report it can generate so it
does have the reference ranges and
although we're not a laboratory we do
try and follow pretty much um what
laboratories do in terms of quality
framework
and reporting of
results so the big question is you know
has icc net really made a difference to
cardiac outcomes in south australia
in the first 12 months we did do a
retrospective order of chest pain and
acs presentations
um basically in the southeast we had six
sites that were part of our network and
then we had the major regional hospital
um that wasn't and they
um
really almost gave us a kind of a
nice controlled study so we actually
compared the patterns of care between
the
hospitals involved with the network and
the big regional hospital that wasn't
involved with a network
inclusion criteria was that they had to
have a history suggestive
of myocardial ischemia and have had at
least one troponin estimation
um
if you look at the evaluation data what
was most important and one of our
performance indicators was that you had
to have a if you're a high risk um
cardiac patient you had to have an
angiography between
48 to 72 hours if you looked at the
non-icarnate sites insights
the time to an angiography was about 6.3
days
in our network we had reduced that to
3.2 days so that was really
promising and it looked also
like the readmissions for these patients
was um considerably less in our network
um
this data across the regional um
southeast
was really quite exciting for us and you
can see the black line shows the the
southern metropolitan area and it shows
you
um
on the um y-axis the in-hospital deaths
for acute coronary syndrome and you can
see that uh in the southern the black
one that started off high but actually
then plateaued around uh four percent
the the red line
is the southeast moving
average and if you look at that as
opposed to the blue line which is the
actual results and bounces around a bit
the red line also
in country you can see the acs regional
desk was high
but considerably higher than the
metropolitan region
the network commenced in 2001 and you
can see that indicated on the graph the
fully regional network started in 2003
and you can start to see that the two
lines merge
um those lines continue to emerge and so
that was twice as really exciting it
looked like we were making a difference
in the
inhospitable mortality for acute
coronary syndrome in in our research
area
we just this year um february this year
we reported on the impact of our
regionalised
network across
south australia and if you're interested
that papers in the medical journal of
australia
so the conclusion to that paper was that
cardiology supported remote risk
stratification management facilitated
and facilitated early access to
to shoe-based invasive management was
associated with an improvement in 30-day
mortality for patients who present to
rural hospitals and are diagnosed with
mi
these interventions close the gap in
mortality between rural and remote um
rural and metropolitan patients in south
australia so if you have a look at this
graph and this is 30-day more totality
for ami between 2001 and 2010
um the red line shows the metropolitan
observed rate and the blue line shows
the rural observer rate and you can see
even with
this regional data the two lines uh have
merged and come together so we have
eliminated that mortality gap which is
you know extremely exciting to us and it
probably explains why
our research is now um no longer
research and it's clinical care within
country health um this graph actually
the shaded area shows you the uptake of
icc net and joining the network and then
you can see um the light gray line
is
the metro and the dark line is the um
rule and again as the uptake of
of icc net increased you can see
um that the 30-day mortality
decreased
so
if you looked at the risk adjusted odds
ratio for deaths at 30 days um
post my for rural versus metro
in 2001 that risk
odds ratio was uh 1.69
and in 2010 it was 0.92
so the implementation of icc net model
of care and rural hospitals was
associated with um 22 reduction in
30-day and moment mortality the beauty
of this was that it wasn't really an
expensive um
system it was really what was needed was
to integrate
all of the bits into a system of care
and to make sure all stakeholders
were aware of the standard process of
dealing with
patients and offering education and
course technical and clinical support
so what lessons did we learn over the
last
seven years
well you need a quality framework and it
has to take taking into account the
limited resources in a busy clinical
environment it has to be not onerous but
effective
when you're
implementing these systems there has to
be flexibility in training programs
you need to have good communication with
all sites
technical support
for the point of care
was extremely important at times that it
is used it is critical because they have
a very sick patient
that relies on that result
um integration into clinical care
incorporating all stakeholders involved
in patient care that was extremely
important if you had engagement of all
there's more likely to be success
if you just put in the point of care and
didn't have any engagement with clinical
clinicians
and it was highly unlikely that that
they would trust that new um technology
or even use those results
multiple modes of training are required
in a dispersed network of limited
resources
so a summary is that point of care has
improved provision of necessary tests
regardless of geographic location or
size resources of the health facility it
has enabled re-engineering of delivery
of services to improve patient safety
clinical outcomes and efficient
utilization of resources and improved
capacity
the provisional point of care was
necessary um but not really on its own
sufficient for the success of this
practice improvement
initiative
and you know most definitely planet care
should be part of an integrated approach
to practice improvement initiatives
so in conclusion our network spanning
980 000 kilometers
based on specialist support and point of
care combined with integrated diagnostic
treatment and triage protocol has
improved the uptake of evidence-based
acute cardiac care for patients with
acute coronary syndrome in country south
australia and has improved patient
outcomes
okay thank you everyone and i hope um
you found that interesting
okay